[Música]
hola me llamo santigua curtis tengo 12
años y estoy seguro que la mayoría de
ustedes se estarán haciendo la misma
pregunta que yo que hago pero bueno
permítanme contarles estoy seguro que
todos pasaron por esa etapa que es la
niñez que es en la que yo estoy ahora
con la que estoy saliendo bueno no sé
pero aunque pronto vendrán las dos
etapas
creo que niñas somos o fuimos todos yo
estoy en esa en la que los adultos te
dicen que estás muy chicos para algunas
cosas y en los cinco minutos te dicen no
te das cuenta que yo esto es grande para
hacer esto hace un ratito nos hacían
volar la imaginación con cuentos
fantásticos y de repente creces y te
hacen pensar todo como un multiple
choice o peor como verdadero o falso
verdadero falso verdadero o falso
pero como el mundo y la vida están
llenas de preguntas unas más raras que
otras yo les voy a hacer un par quienes
de acá creyeron alguna vez en papá noel
levanten la mano
y en los reyes magos
y el ratón pérez
ya pueden bajar las manos
y ahora les pregunto quienes actualmente
siguen creyendo en ellos
la respuesta de muchos buenos pero hay
muchos otros por sí y no se animaron a
levantar la mano por miedo vergüenza
como le pasó un amigo le decían inmaduro
infantil ya estás grande como para creer
en esas cosas y yo me pregunto por qué
entonces me puse a pensar y se me
ocurrieron algunas posibles respuestas
como por usar la imaginación por pensar
demasiado por usar la creatividad por
pensar en cosas que por ahí no existen o
simplemente por no pensar como adulto
pero me di cuenta que supuestamente los
adultos piensan demasiado los adultos
creen en cosas que por ahí no existen y
que para otros adultos las cosas que
cree ese adulto no existen como pueden
ser los dioses de las religiones
entonces me quedé pensando que eso debe
tener que ver con la creatividad con la
imaginación con la que tendemos al mundo
ya que la mayoría de adultos no las usan
o creen que no las necesitan quiero que
me digan si alguna vez vieron algún
adulto o adulta jugando a qué tiene que
derrotar un grabar
ya que es una
guau qué es una que está derrotando un
dragón solo porque quiere
entonces a veces a los chicos se nos
considera inmaduros o infantiles
simplemente por no pensar como uno ya
que los adultos no creen en estas cosas
sólo había uno o dos con la mano
pero nosotros no somos adultos somos
chicos
por ejemplo si un adulto cree en alguna
religión ya es una religión raro la más
normal de la vida se supone que uno debe
ser educado y respetarlo y que cuando
uno está bien educado no debe ir y
matarse de risa en la cara de un
religioso mientras hace sus rituales
raritos pero porque si cuando un chico
dice que cree en papá noel en mi opinión
es simplemente porque es chico porque si
hay un nene religioso todos los respetan
y no creo que sea por ser nene en mi
opinión es simplemente por creer en algo
en lo que los adultos creen
también me puse a pensar otras
situaciones en las que a nosotros los
chicos se nos considera menos o
inferiores me acordé de un canal de
youtube que hace lo que se llama pro my
life que es dibujar tu vida mientras
contar tu vida mientras la dibujase en
una pizarra pero los de este canal no
dibujaban su vida
dibujaba en la vida de famosos cuentas
historias de terror libros mitologías
monstruos etcétera encontró un vídeo que
era una recopilación de historias de
terror japonesas que ellos ya habían
contado en otros vídeos y en una de esas
historias contaban que había un espíritu
de una señora que sólo atacaba a los
niños porque son más fáciles de engañar
y entonces claro yo me quedé como desde
cuando en todo caso ustedes los adultos
nos hacen más fáciles de engañar
por ejemplo si un papel es adulto le
hizo el hijo mira eso él apareció el
dragón peluffo no quiere decir que el
chico sea tonto y no sepa que eso es una
lámpara y en caso de no saberlo y pensar
realmente que eso es un gran no tiene
nada de malo porque por lo menos se está
divirtiendo los chicos no somos los
chicos no somos adultos somos chicos y
eso el peso no es fácil de entender es
cierto que por ahí un nene de primaria
no sabe algo que un adulto sí sabe pero
eso no lo hace menos inteligente y no
quiere decir que no pueda saberlo porque
en mi opinión las pocas diferencias
entre un adulto y un chico son el físico
los cambios naturales el físico los
cambios capacidades o la fuerza
pero dije bueno a ver en qué otros
momentos podemos resultar engañados y me
di cuenta que no sólo las familias o las
escuelas nos pueden engañar o hacer
creer creer cosas que no son sino que
también
el cine el internet la tele etcétera y
ese fue el momento en el que me acordé
de la cigüeña
la famosa cigüeña
la verdad nunca conocí a nadie que sus
papás les dijeran que a los bebés a los
hijos los traerá su dueña pero si tenía
amigos que lo querían por la tele o por
ver pelis muchos llamar a la cigüeña
mentira a mí no me gusta llamarla así
prefiero llamar la verdad o verda
disfrazada o sea está disfrazada para
ocultar algo tiene una razón de ser
ahora cuando soy frase cree
verdaderamente deja de ser un disfraz y
la cigüeña se convierte en verdad pero
por qué porque nos hacen creer esto es
como llamarnos incapaces de saber la
verdad y no estoy diciendo que la
cigüeña sea mala estoy preguntando por
qué se considera buena
después cuando crecemos nos dicen que
los chicos hacen con amor y con amor lo
mismo que con la cigüeña a ver cuando se
hacen los hijos se supone que hay amor
pero si pedimos la verdad queremos la
verdad nos hablan de la cigüeña del amor
cuál es la parte que no nos quieren
contar
al menos los reyes magos y papá noel nos
hacen pasar por momentos divertidos pero
la cigüeña
bueno pasando a otro tema aunque
bastante más serio tiene que ver con la
violencia la pobreza o las injusticias
que también forman parte de la realidad
no creo que esté bueno que por ejemplo
en un juego o en un libro haya demasiada
violencia pero pensemos qué pasaría si
los chicos no sabemos que la violencia
existe efectivamente no habría chicos
violentos pero no sé si sería más
peligroso para nosotros porque los
adultos que sí conoce la violencia se
aprovecharían de nuestra inocencia y no
lo digo porque ahora no pasa
entonces lo que quiero decir es que no
estaba bueno con chicos es ni siquiera
un poquito violento pero imagínense si
no se entera de nada de las cosas que
pasan actualmente básicamente sólo
estaría apartando de la realidad y la
realidad está lejos de ser perfecta y la
única manera de cambiarla es entendiendo
la y aprendiendo la
y bueno haciendo lo que los adultos
vienen haciendo la realidad está como
está no estaría bueno usar más la
imaginación y la creatividad para
cambiarla
[Aplausos]
además el mundo también nos pertenece a
los chicos descubrirme y mejorarlo es
una tarea que también nos pertenece no
nos dejen afuera muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]